thank you
Gold Eagle actual Shadow one is weapons
hot
we're burning daylight here coffee grave
standby well as well do we have
confirmation watch your one two Bravo
zero seven
are you in position
[Music]
coming
I'll give him that I get up there and
let's see what he's up to in the middle
of nowhere
Amazon what do you see
on Personnel armor and Hardware or
Russian what the hell are the Russians
doing with core Prime money supply in
Iran it's an arms deal you're copying
the shadow one affirmative two birds one
stone we need positive ID on cobrani
before we kick this off boys ghost can
you identify the general armed escorts
around one VIP
Russians are very happy to see him it'll
be the last time they have to do
ghost do you have positive ID on Google
visual on General gabrani
copy all stations Target confirmed she
had a one you were cleared hot for
launch Roger that actual ghost you are
danger close to the Zone this arrow is
gonna pack a punch copy approved
Sunday all stations Shadow one missile
is ready for immediate delivery standby
for launch es
pistol in blue
manual guidance to hold her missile
bearing Northeast 065 degrees at Mach 3
altitude 500 meters check your heading
Shadow one bearing is good
right in the pocket stay with it yeah
direct Target destroyed
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
you would be the first to know sir damn
right I would talk to me
we have a hit Uncle brownie second in
command
Force Major
picking up the mantle for Iran supplying
terrorists money weapons Intel well he's
ambitious he's dangerous sir he wants
retaliation for the gurani strike
he's planning something
we can't take him any wrong
he's not in Iran sir he's on the ground
in all masra what the hell is he doing
in our there is only one way to find out
sir
well let's get him
when
what time is it now
[Music]
who do we send
Wheels open five Roger Marines are
loading in now you and the sergeant are
being away on this sergeant
let's get ourselves a winning LT
C sir
yes sir any issues negative sir out here
airstrikes are hitting enemy positions
bordering on nasra Intel confirms the
concentration of AQ Fighters converging
in the valley we believe they're
protecting something surveillance
indicates soldiers guarding three
structures major Hassan may be holed up
inside
ghost and soak will lead a marine
Special Operations unit to kill or
capture Hassan tonight
one Hilo will insert two teams at
separate offset points bordering the
target area bravo team will sweep in
clear buildings one and two Alpha Team
takes building three all Shooters have
execute Authority but we want Hassan
alive for interrogation
and be advised major Hassan is aq's
lifeline
if he is there they will die for him
good hunting
robot team off floats here Alpha Team
stays on board to land downrange both
teams meet in the middle
remember you want a son alive but this
is capture or kill
keep up so
probably Floyd
oh clear
search it let's find what they were
hiding
no control has got some serious in here
what the [ __ ] is this
it's all in English
ballistic missiles some of our launcher
these will go a thousand miles at least
how the hell did Iran get their hands on
this
7-6 gas through to Laswell Roger standby
bravo 7-6 charlie to watch her one how
copy this is what you're
last well this is Ghost we've got
something
tell me you found her son ghost
take a look at this
ghost do you have a son negative we
found a weapons cache a song's got
missiles
they're American
it's your last I'll say again as soon as
America missiles
all right clear the room
let's go everybody out now
foreign
is in possession of American missiles
American missiles and accused handsome
his son has been passing out our
ballistic missiles like it's [ __ ]
Halloween and we didn't know about it
because Iran plausible deniability oh
deniability my ass it runs all over this
I want to know how many they have and
where they intend to use them if Hassan
is moving missiles he has a smuggling
partner well then I would advise you to
find out who that is
give my team two hours with those
missiles sir I will know everybody's
on them negative I want them destroyed
General there's valuable Intel there
this is an intelligence failure last
well it's not going to be a tactical one
there will be 500 enemy soldiers on that
site by Sunrise we need a win fast
Gold Eagle axle to ghost move your team
and call for fire I want those weapons
destroyed
Roger the actual Amsterdam
the hell's Amsterdam got to do with this
it's a smuggling hub
Watson canals are insecure Iran has
friends there
we do too
who the captain
he's tracking an AQ cell in country as
we speak
well that's the first good news I've
heard all day
I'll link up with him and handle this
myself sir
he lies well back in the field
I want this done right
no mistakes my sentiments exactly
Kate
I want Hassan boxed up and gift wrapped
until then
you keep this tight
what's your ETA less than an hour where
are you now who knows under a bridge
watching the night Cuba I said carrying
a missile container
negative not this one let's hope it
leads to the one that does
[Music]
he said good income let's get after it
[Applause]
well that's where we're in position
[Applause]
EQ loading can't go into a barge that's
your target get a board and find out who
they're working with
Roach
sentries on the perimeter
yeah and congrats all over the dogs
take them out to get to the barge
you two get to work out
oh that splits up don't say the outside
you clean up the dogs
stay quiet
let me go to barge check
when you come
all clear
it's his phone
get it
God tells meeting with AQ
as well I find cafe cracked something's
about to go down when one hour
[Music]
level six to what you want this is the
cafe
until the time was my three o'clock one
cartel one Iranian
what are they up to
conducting a transaction
boom
they're paying the cartel for something
about what security
copy I'm coming your way now
syringe poison
welcome to my world
use the needle on the guards and we roll
up our cartel friend wouldn't you
say when Roger that
zero six
online
when are they moving
they're mine
guys bring the syringe
[Applause]
Kevin
let's get him up
oh
[ __ ]
what's up
it's on the move
yeah on my way
nice work you too
we need to find where they're moving
Hassan anymore
took
I can be very persuasive
[Music]
Colonel Vargas the station I thought we
were on a first name basis this must be
serious
cartel is smuggling an Iranian terrorist
over the Border as well terrorists don't
cross the southern border we know that
and they know that and that is exactly
why they're gonna do it
I need you to stop it who's my target
copy when tonight
tapped into a surveillance drone Maison
got movement down there
whatever they're always responding
they could be moving
copy where's FBI on this FBI is an hour
out right now you're all we got standby
number four
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
burn everything
I don't know who I am you're a terrorist
pinnacle
I'm a soldier
and I'm here to fight
no let him burn as good brownie bird
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my son was taken back into cartel
protection in Los Alamos Mexican Special
Forces confirmed Hassan is moving
something sizable towards the U.S the
cargo could be containers housing
missiles we don't know how many and we
don't know the targets to find out we
need to capture Hassan and bring him in
for interrogation we'll send soap and
ghost to link up with the Mexican
special forces in country along with all
the Manpower they need we can't start a
war in Mexico general we're certainly
not I'll task Philip graves in his
shadow company pmcs to assist their
Rules of Engagement can help us gut some
red tape and get this done understood
sir let's fight the Sun
thank you
Alejandro Sergeant McDonald
[Applause]
last one says they call you ghost
actually I believe he prefers how to
welcome to the city of Souls
I've never been to Mexico she's in
Mexico
Shepherd's contractors are inbound to
reinforce their bringing Hardware
they'll need room my face is your race
good now where's the sun got the safe
house 10 clicks from here get in
oh yeah
it's my second in command sergeant major
role for Bangla
they think
you know Spanish
no
you will
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
play truck four under the back easy
it's normal here
guns on the street is jurisdiction of
the police where the police
has a very serious problem there are a
few here to uphold the law and many of
those who resist corruption
disappear what about the military or
because we are well trained soldiers are
recruited by the narcos why not you
you grew up here
because Vaqueros
will die fighting for it
[Applause]
gets guns and balloons
it's a new one nauticals use generosity
to win over the people even the children
especially the children
also no sheets
cartel clothes
warnings marking territory
which relates with death
Lucy nombre
the nameless the
[Music]
where can we find him you can't no one
knows who he is
but he is everywhere and this is a
challenge
for those volcanoes like challenges
with their mask you will fit in well if
you go
[Music]
find is the army
turn right
[Music]
some troops are in the pocket of us like
I told you he is everywhere
Adele is hiding a song in the village
across the river so still there
[Music]
leaders
where are they holding their sign why do
Sony building back a town
civilians gone
Let's Roll
I'll drive
with some fire from the sky
let's wrap this [ __ ] up grapes no copy
we are pushing to the Target
they have said heading for that compound
right fire Ops keep your hand on that
hot switch we're gonna get started here
solid copy pilot you have the con once
on Station Circle the target bring us
around sir come get me General Shepherd
Rod stand by Shepherd's up Sir Gold
Eagle actual this is Shadow one how copy
loud and clear Shadow one send traffic I
had to bail your boys out luckily they
have friends in high places that's what
you're there for tell
we got a hit on Hassan approaching the
Target location now we'll get this
bastard rolled up for a little talking
to him that's what I like to hear report
back when Hassan's in the bag Roger that
out here
all Shadows listen up these guys on the
ground Mexican Special Forces one four
one they are your brothers now treat
them like your own and let's get this
done yeah all right
ghost is a shadow one orbiting the
compound now standing by the fish
Minecraft shadow one Bravo zero seven
will Mark our position with ir laser
over Roger there zero seven how do we
find Hassan he'll have an armed guard
can't tell protection a lot of places to
hide Raves cops went close there we
clear the buildings
with iot
Marcus
Shadow one we're each to the compound
position
[Music]
off the trigger copy
TV friendlies are marked with ir laser
confirm visual
s
shut the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
one [ __ ] Sinker that's what I'm
talking about Shadows you know I love
that [ __ ]
grapes actual make my day we got him
escorting back to base as we speak make
it quick we can't hold him for long
Roger that
on your knees
y'all got a clear picture
Crystal
all set
all right you're alive folks
you speak Arabic no before I see
no
of course not
and I'll speak your bastard there is
Medieval English
because you're all uneducated Street
dogs ah see we're getting off to a bad
start here son you're talking to
alcott's Force officer
you're the commander of a foreign Terror
organization
I can say the same to you what's your
target
major what was your target when you send
muscles to my land oh wild gas to now
your ass so insolent and foul mouth
you will learn to respect me when your
nation sees fire
you are in bed with the cartel Hassan if
you disappeared no one would know where
to look for the [ __ ] stain
I have no doubt you'll take pleasure in
torturing me who'd you get American
missiles from I don't care who they're
from I want to know where they're going
take a look around Hassan
now you can either become part of the
food chain
or you can start talking
I'm a hostage here
this is illegal you are a prisoner of
war Iran is not a war with Mexico
I've broken no laws these men and their
commanders are the lawbreakers you and
your beloved
you executed him and you will pay for
your crimes
I want this bastard in permanent custody
or looking up at the goddamn grass
killing Hassan is an act of War keeping
him as illegal right now he is hot to
hold
tell me you're getting something
actionable as well
standby
there's nothing I would like more
but laswell's right with
I would have to begin with him from his
phone
affirmative we gotta hit
good
now take it back and let him go
[Music]
to Mexico went into a cell power off the
coast of Spain Hassan is communicating
with someone there when we caught him
signals trapped to a hatchery used by
the cartel as a smuggling front it's
remote and all the water perfect to move
illegal cargo including missiles we need
to get on the ground and see if the
missiles are there imagery shows at
least four structures on a light down
swinging eyes inside but it's heavily
guarded by Cartel the high glass lends
itself to concealments in iraqia Julie
suits exactly I'll watch the coast for
movement provide X full by boat please
[Music]
already a crowd but we have no
jurisdiction here John we will load and
slow this is unauthorized to recount by
fire we're off the books
let's find these missiles before his son
puts them in our backyard
[Music]
foreign
to Bravo I'm in position
half a click off the coast structures
are visible with your status
your green lit execute enabled
standby
guys
no wind
200 meters
on me
Bravo what do you have
Bravo how copy
solid water
two down
I wasn't mobile Patrols in the ground
team ahead of us
scope Insurgent let's see what we're
doing
let's go
we need to get Laswell back let's move
this is a proof of life
where did this come from
no that Point's an ace likely to El
mazura they go underground there will
Lucifer good we'll leave the rescue too
that's not gonna happen
say again Jim
let's win since now
planning and preparation things take
violence and timing I can do both Kate's
life is in a [ __ ] hourglass
I know you're upset captain
this happened on your mission that's a
tough pill to swallow
you said to me we leave her I'm telling
you I can't help you
but it won't stop you
I love her back in 12 hours
okay with your friend
about friends it's about the enemies
good luck
be going head-to-head with IQ on that
hooked up we're gonna have hundreds more
protecting lands we need not probably
because there's an army
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
age or female
because
you stay in the helium OverWatch we'll
work our way up the line Roger that
list in the hood get Laswell back
ah thanks for the assistant she had a
common enemy I've got a friend in need
what's that
see you down the road
all stations
chicken
kite
it's over
it's over
it's a family reunion
we'll miss it
nice moves as well
you too
all of you we're in our mouths wrong
we're gonna get somewhere safe now
Captain's right
[Laughter]
sorry thank you I owed you one well
there's the other way around what even
then with our feet is
until next time captain
I'm sorry John it's okay
John stop I'm fine
I've got bigger problems
missiles were never in Spain the
guidance systems part Garden systems
where the hell did they get those
Russians
where are they now
and aside from Hassan there's only one
person who knows where to find them
because of this enormous
cartel left tenant
my sources tell me all the VIPs in Los
Alamos will be there tonight
some are invited others are voluntol yes
what's meet about Nosotros
that's almost is burning and they want
to know lit the fire it's a number I
will be there yeah
no guarantees but this is our best child
then we take it I got enough Shadows
here to take over the whole damn country
I'd prefer it if you did it just saying
one house shouldn't be a problem I need
sin ombre alive
well
then we need to meet him
oh
give them what they want Intel they want
to know who's here let's tell them in
person
correct though get one of us inside find
the boss
roll them up
I'll do it you go in there
I'll take my chances
I came here to stop a messiah let's stop
it
I'll offer Intel for a meet with sonomri
and if he's there
pumps not only Dina's well what's going
on did you make it in when he dies and
ears I'll go too I'll take OverWatch
Shadow circles the Target in a Helo
Roger that
they are going to want proof
shown this
call me when you need me all right let's
Gear Up get after it
got ozone station
copy we'll say yeah
down on the roof Chuck
eyes on two armed at the front door
gosh damn how'd you do that violently
visual on soap
they do now
they're taking them in
kids got sand
nobody makes it
[Music]
normal
Valeria I didn't clean sight hiding
good so are we
let's go
for tomorrow
I know her
I'm sick all right how do you two know
each other no it's a strong word yes
yeah
that was Denver
I don't take orders anymore
even the dogs in Las Almas know not to
bark at me she's ex-military we serve
together
different squads
same unit
ignore the Wild Ones
Los Vaqueros
my squad was clean cuts
to the raid on the sun yeah
that's exactly what we did when you get
down he's enforces because you were his
enforcers huh he was escorted to the
mountains without incident
also to prevent Bloodshed he was
supposed to go to prison
so you kill him
and you took over
I created a power vacuum and I filled it
because soldiers
instead
you disgrace the army
[Music]
Hermanos no
why are you doing this
you tell me
you're the contractor no
what you don't do your competitors will
you're a knockout Opera and a terrorist
terrorism is good for business
it's Insurance what the [ __ ] does that
mean
s
as long as there is a war on terror
there will be no real War on Drugs
to find your so-called terrorists and
your missiles you need me
to prevent bloodshed I'm not doing this
it doesn't change anything it changes
everything
don't make a deal with her
warning well
looks like it's your turn to tell the
truth
I want the Nationals I want the Target
and I want a son
and you've got 10 seconds or I'm going
to show you the difference between
military and me
I don't know the targets
Courier I move things
[Music]
when you return
I'll tell you where Hassan is in
exchange you will let me go and get the
[ __ ] out of us
[Music]
until then you're staying right here
coordinates obtained through
interrogation confirm an oil rig 400
nautical miles offshore in the Gulf of
Mexico the rig is no longer active and
is currently in use by the cartel as a
smuggling dead drop a cargo ship is
anchored 500 meters to its Northwest
surveillance saw Personnel moving a
large container from the ship to the rig
that container is now on top of the
platform we believe this is the missile
df-141 Colonel Vargas and Shadow company
will infill three boat teams for a
simultaneous takedown of both targets
ghost will lead the ship assault team
Graves soap and Alejandro will engage
the oil rig and disarm the missile all
Shooters will give No Quarter your
orders are to eliminate all threads
let's invite ourselves in
station
God help me God help us all be ready for
anything
but be a trap
well we're set copy get to work
on this platform
full containment
making history
Target updated
let's enjoy our handiwork sergeant
here we go all stations prepared for the
Boom
[ __ ]
Andre you okay
Gold Eagle actual shadow of one good hit
good hit missile and rig destroyed copy
that shadow one good work to get off
that X go home
thanks for a job well done
Roger the actual
brought to be men
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's this
this is the immediate tuition step away
from the gate
what you heard me are you crazy
this is my base not a base this is a
sizable Cobra facility
and I admire that
so I'm taking
you boys have been relieved thank you
for your service I don't know I don't
take orders from you
didn't Valeria say that
now that makes me wonder what else I
don't know about your affiliation with a
drug lord
what the [ __ ] did you just say to me
Penn Hills line griefs don't do that
don't
do that
no one needs to get hurt here
are you threatening US soldier I don't
make threats
I make guarantees so let's not do this
I'm calling Shepard General Shepard
sends his regards
he told me all wouldn't take this well
he knows about this
he's put me in command of this operation
from here on out so you all need to
stand down it's time to let the pros
finish this
why the hell are we talking like this is
some kind of negotiation it's not
I've got my orders and now you have
yours and who the [ __ ] do you think you
are cabron
my men are inside I'm afraid not
your men have been
detained
[Applause]
[Applause]
down there so go
foreign
[Music]
that was a big mistake brother
did not have to be like this
[Applause]
find him
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sending transpo to your location for all
prisoners standby reinforcements in the
North Plaza now
this is Bravo sipping one in the blind a
copy
seven one do you copy
ah where are you ghost
foreign
Johnny take shotgun
why Johnny
you made it
we made it healthy
that's one way of doing it get back
thanks drive
where are we Alejandro's safe house
getting the location just in case why
didn't he tell me it was neat to know
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
soap ghost your life affirmative
to see you Amigos amigo nice throw
where were you guys
on the run I was on the Run ghost waited
for me of course no no yes
we're a team all of us
this happened on my watch and I'll need
help to fix it
no one fights alone
why did Graves turn we don't know Los
Alamos can corrupt anyone not us for now
General Shepherd Laswell and anyone else
outside this room is considered a
hostile with one exception Alejandro we
need him back then
grapes is holding him here his own
personal blacks like prison my team is
locked in there too how do we get him
back by breaking in that's why I love
the ghost it's gonna take more than this
won't stop all right come on man we're
gonna need new wheels preferably up
armored
[Music]
Alejandro thought of everything yay
let's go get him
the old prison is in a remote area
outside Las Almas it was maximum
security until the narcos took over and
it was permanently closed there is no
airstrip but expect hilos for security
and resupply we'll drive to an offset
and rock up to our infill yeah if the
security towers are man we'll need to
take them out first and rope up the wall
for entry what about cameras there's
cctvs in the security room we'll use
them to locate Alejandro and the rest of
your men let's divide and conquer while
Rudy finds out I'll use the calms to
help ghosts plant charges and key areas
diversions are sabotage nice Johnny I
learned from the best LT once we
pinpoint Alejandro and Los Vaqueros we
regroup and pry him loose we'll carry
extra guns into arm my men and fight our
way out the way we came in any questions
what are we waiting for
graves will have this place locked down
expect patrols on the outside No Doubt
could get up
guns armor and charges in the Pikes I've
got the putter gun ascenders check check
I saw Pollyanna was alive count on it on
me
goodbye
Roger that
we're clear for now the Shadows are on
the way count on it
good to see you Captain ghost Gary Bryce
how'd you know Laswell as soon as
Shepherd went dark she called us Laswell
still saw it as a rock Colonel Vargas
meet Captain Price and Sergeant Garrick
thanks for the assist my mind guys so
ghost OverWatch now
oh sure attack Rodolfo you take the
truck we came with me
This Is Us
Shepard burned us he said Grace the
Shadows to kill us around the Boston
carols we know why
truth
I uncovered redacted Intel regarding a
black bag operation conducted by General
Shepard and carried out a shadow company
they were transacting American-made
ballistic misses to our allies fighting
Russians in the Middle East
the mission
this time Graves
if I told you I'd have to kill you I bet
he'd do it too
there's nothing but a milk run boys guns
for the good guys he'll be back here at
HQ for breakfast
don't [ __ ] the bed and there'll be
bonuses all around
find me when you're back yep yep
Jeffers waiting for a sit rep don't
leave them hanging out three containers
that's a little [ __ ] milk
thirsty friends
Shadow 2 to Gold Eagle actual 10 traffic
too
three Shadow Victors exiting Highway 7
Zulu no issues actual
copy get that cargo delivered on time do
not fail eagle out
do not fail
told you this [ __ ] was important
what's this
three this is Erickson what's up
standby coming to you
Grace Vance be advised we're held up
sorting it out now
handle it keep the line moving Roger
that
reconnaissance said the route was clear
of enemy activity
the reports were wrong
the shipment was spotted before it
arrived at its destination
I don't like this it's Arabic is
atrocious
[Music]
lean out and cover him
advance to Paulo go help him out
the [ __ ] contest
ugh
Shadows characters
[Applause]
foreign
the Russians executed the entire Squad
and got a hold of Shadows comes
they learned Shepard was behind it
Russia gave the missiles to Hassan
Shepherd's intentions were good but the
shipments were illegal and off the books
he engraves buried it
and the cover-up is always worse than
the crime
we were getting too close and they
weren't going to let that happen
three missiles were stolen
we've only found two
Hassan's got one more
we need to find it
you hit this why we all keep secrets
Captain what hell was I informed
consider yourself well informed now John
oh that's really [ __ ] helpful General
thank you but you weren't they like to
miss our short list three of them we
only found two then Point yourself in
that direction and fix it and it fixes
you right
I don't need fixing I'm a patriot
protecting my country I'm protecting
your own art
I do what needs to be done and no one
holds me down with a roll of red tape I
know what's best for the car you've lost
your mind General and you've forgotten
what you're fighting for John
to do good you've got to do some bad
when we [ __ ] we bury it that's how it
works yeah
we don't bury each other with it do we
turn off that side of your head
and face down the Real Enemy
you need to cool off your shadow
Graves yeah
he's a dog with a bone and I highly
recommend you don't try and take it
you lost Jones to change your mind then
what
then after I'll go for him I'm coming
for you
[Music]
[Applause]
finally attention
all right listen
we are taking back your HQ
you're getting our prisoner
we are killing Commander Graves when now
[Music]
is a fight against our own
we are not one for one and lost for
keros on this retained
goes to him
[Music]
good to see you again Soma
if you're in take a mask if you're not
boom
foreign
[Music]
high alert because of the prison break
we'll infiltrate the base with two ghost
teams team one is Captain Price guys me
and one pilot team two is ghosts so Rudy
and Los Vaqueros team one will use the
tunnels to get to the tarmac and
commandir a Hilo my pilot will take the
captain up team two will stand by
outside until price fires on the entry
gate and lets the to find a way to the
witch Grace I suspect it'll be in my HQ
defended by his best Shooters well guys
and we located secure Valeria ghosting
two will find Graves and kill them
puppy we're close to work affirmative
one click through the gate we saw the
ghost got me hold tight out good work
Alejandro guys thank you six Miss Love
what's it called six or seven let's hope
it still works faces
full ghost on wheels up with eyes on
copy that
two is inbound to the gate your cleared
heart when Target is marked
greatest in the HQ holding his ground
once we're in we split up close air
clears away with shadows on the Run we
locate Graves and kill him comprende
so get the designates remark targets for
price in the Helo
Roger
it's locked Rudy what do you got reach
your charge nice clear to engage your
threads inside if you see great drop him
hey ready sorry about your base
it's it three two one X
[Music]
is
[Music]
inside copy give him son place where we
put each other's stay quiet if you want
to live some coffee
now we secure this position on the south
coast and really take Graves Gaza Bravo
6 prisoner secure
we're going for Grace
yeah something a little stronger
[Music]
that's locked Rudy what do you got read
your charge nice way to engage inside if
you see Graves dropping hey really sorry
about your base
set it three two one execute
contact second deck
he's on the Run clearing
let's find him
I gotcha go on
let's end this [ __ ]
of course you're coming no price and the
pilot need help you two finish this look
that's not ours
oh [ __ ] grape straw [ __ ] type you
ready for this hell yeah
the day after him
[Music]
you did it so you and me hermano brought
a gun to a tank fight
yeah we did
show up The Ghost and we're ready Braves
Kia
house price hungry lost a good cigar in
the crash Pilots okay too ow Alejandro
vamos
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we grow or we die it's the way of the
world
I put a Target in Chicago now [ __ ]
leave Los Almas and go find it now
is yours
I look forward to it
let's go
[Music]
so proper transport get last well I
sounded a missed holler in Chicago
[Music]
I'll be free in 24 hours
can't say the same about you Vaqueros
you're going down for what you did it
doesn't matter what I did it matters
what you can prove
oh yeah
keep finding the good fight hermano do I
better end my brother
good luck Amigos
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
told us the third missile was smuggled
into the United States through the port
of Chicago
Hassan and his EQ soldiers are with it
you don't know exactly where the missile
is or where it's headed
mistake it's more building in Downtown
Chicago owned by a shell company of the
Los Alamos Casa police are on the ground
coordinating off streets around the
building they're on the lookout for a
stolen Container full of weapons they do
not know we're dealing with a missile We
Believe Hassan has held up in a
fortified server room on the 54th floor
of this building I will be on the ground
working to locate the missile all in
full with the Marines on the Chicago
River and move in on the ground level
highly up to an OP across from the
objective from OverWatch we'll touch two
healers down on the road for the Target
building one with the super Marines the
other would mean so while gas and the
Marines push up the building prices so
we'll work their way down with so
propelling to the server floor punching
us down in the middle
primary missions to locate stop the
missile but you have execute authority
to kill Hassan
watch a one to Bravo 6 actual perimeter
is secure we have a possible hit on the
missile container we're moving in now
solid coffee
[Applause]
's up
12062 is 20 seconds on the target
building it's our report
go sketch you OverWatch
456 is our primary objective it's about
four to five with limited access son
maybe hold up there
copy let's nail this bastard once and
for all so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ghost soap
watch the window
attacking
we are fading
[Music]
perfect show LT
you called it sergeant
or stations
Assad's down enemy Kia
officials are saying a power surge is to
blame for an explosion over downtown
Chicago last night due to severe winds
leaving thousands of residents in the
dark electricity is expected to be
restored by the Phoenix
creative writing
I'll never tell
thank you
ran called cells
Ruffins
Shepherd
shadow
they got past us
[Music]
it's gone out of snakes
[Music]
and he's done a shepherd
totally Off the Grid well we'll find him
a bigger fish
I've done some digging on the Russians
well that's a dirty joke
Ultra National established that Convoy
John okay this is over no it's not
they're working with someone new
[Music]
we don't know his name
[Music]
who is he
Makarov
s
leave chicken or fish gentlemen salads
please
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]